refreshed and ready for a second day of
deciphering non-humuni non-human
communication
we'll start out today with Roberto
um take it away
can you hear me
thanks a lot for being here today and
thanks for the organizer for the
organizer for cooking up such a nice
event
um I'm Roberto Lucy and I'm a last year
PhD student at UPF as part of an
industrial PhD with uh with met I in
Paris
today I'll be talking about deep
emerging communication a bit about the
field how it started the basic research
question behind it how things are going
now and possibly how they look ahead in
the future and I want to acknowledge
that I benefited from interacting with
the manual in Paris what the rain is
presentation and also the material that
I'm showing is partially adapted from a
tutorial that me and Marco brownie my
supervisor and angelicular
gave at emnlp
um at the end of 2022.
um so I'll talk a bit about what we mean
with deep emerging communication
um hopefully verifying what does deep
emergent communication means
um talking a bit about the standard
setup which is used in the experimental
setup views uh which is the
communication game uh sort of being some
relevant results and some work that we
did in the area
um and then the second part talking a
bit about what it means to do deep
emerging communication
when big powerful models like large
language models are available
an experiment on using of the short
Communication in multi-model language
models and then a bit of speculation on
where the field might go ahead and some
connection with the non-newman
communication or it's really admokers
English
so if I if I were to
um hope to give you one tickle message
from this presentation is that you
wouldn't be asking this question at the
end of the talk
um or if you would or to research
somebody asking you wouldn't say
something like
um answering to can some explain to me
what is emerging communication you
wouldn't say I don't understand why
people care about the problem what's the
application it seems like an irrelevant
research area to me and this is from a
Reddit thread that I found or maybe even
worse you wouldn't say do you mean the
satellite telephone or message which is
used to connect someone in another
situation
yes that was my reaction
um before like crying but
um
so actually this is not emerging
communication what we mean why we say
emerging communication but instead what
um what emerging communication tries to
do is motivated by the observation that
human intelligence relies on the ability
to communicate and use language to
interact and engage in complex social
behaviors I think David put it nicely
yesterday during the introduction but
like we got here um yesterday and today
to collaborate in order to achieve much
more
um together than we can achieve alone
and I think the the very powerful uh
medium that we use to achieve this
collaboration is language it allows us
to coordinate and engage and interact in
very Dynamic and complex situations
so this is with humans how's the uh
Trend in deep neural network instead
deep neural agents so the in the recent
years many new powerful architectures
have been produced uh Transformer been
around I think we've heard
naming them or all over the place
yesterday then some other architecture
like Inception bird
um their performance have improved and
they started powering interesting
applications being applied for an
interesting use cases from protein
folding to
um beating humans at very complex games
or powering um search engines and
they're very good at doing this single
applications and for this reason a
question arises on whether they could
they could also learn to coordinate and
like human do cooperate and use language
to unlock new more complex abilities
for this reason if I were to give a
definition of what deep emerging
communication is is the field of
research where the agents with no
pre-existing communication protocol
engage in interaction
and in this interaction their goal
um is to bootstrap to cooperate while
bootstrapping a communication protocol
which acts as a sort of shared language
and this shared language that gets
created as a as an effect of the
interaction as some nice properties that
we are interested in studying and trying
to understand
um
from a more like experimental point of
view
it's not a it is a very
multi-disciplinary field
um encompassing very sub uh encompassing
very different disciplines from
Linguistics to computer science AI
um and it can be used to investigate
different
um questions so for instance Can it can
be used as an experimental framework for
language emergence and evolution this is
due to the fabric we are sort of Evol
letting the agents evolve their own
language
um and it can be used to study
linguistic hypothesis connected to how
language can be acquired how language
can be can get created through social
interaction or how it can evolve through
generation as an effect of things like
social learning
another
um interesting aspect that can be
studied is the fact that this is an
alternative Paradigm compared to how
neural networks are learning language
nowadays so in large language models I
think there was somebody explaining it
yesterday as well these models are
learning language by being exposed
passively to loads amount of written
texts to trillion tokens and they and
simply by learning to predict the next
token they bootstrap their own
linguistic skills whereas here in this
alternative view the uh language
learning inspired by how humans interact
is um is learned through
um cooperation and continuous
interaction
and finally
um if we are able to let this model
interact and communicate we might might
able to give them a possibility to
unlock new capabilities and coordinate
among themselves to achieve things like
having a division of labor
specialization of labors and unlock new
um
interesting capabilities
um if I think you are more interested in
the in the scientific aspect of the
question then I think the um the first
sub-area is what what's more relevant
for people
um which is related to more like
scientific endeavors
sort of incrementally going to towards
more like engineering and applied
questions of how we can actually create
some some working
application that uses agents to
coordinate
um and all these aspects are not
Standalone blocks but they um interact
and ideas sort of like flow between each
sub subfield
um and doing research in emerging
communication really means sort of like
moving towards these circles and
oftentimes being in the middle of at the
intersection of of two of this
so if we after after this her brief
introduction we got an idea of what is
deep emerging communication and now I'm
I'm going to be covering the standard
setup the communication game which is um
which is not the only one there are
others that have been used but this is
very likely the most
um the most use even its Simplicity and
how it can let us investigate specific
questions in a controlled setup
communication game is depicted as
follows so we have an agent you can see
there is like your favorite general
purpose neural network
um that gets an input it can be for
instance an image this orange air and it
needs to come up with the description it
is a message of this image which is a um
possibly a sequence of discrete tokens
that can have a variable length
uh and this message uh gets generated by
the descender agent it gets passed
through the receiver
which gets us input a list of candidates
including
um the target input uh which again is
the image of the orange chair
um and needs to come up with a decision
on where it thinks the um object related
to the message is placed in the in the
list
after this continuous interaction the
way we I mean during this continuous
interaction the way we um teach this
model uh how to do the task is to give
them feedback which is a shared uh
reward that's why it's a competitive
task
and the goal is whether the receiver
agent was able to correctly guess the
position
and this is the only reward that that we
provide to the agent while they're
training
and what we call language is actually
this
um this mapping from meanings so they on
the input side to messages
that starts as random given that the
agent
to the standard receiver always
um
not necessarily but um and they also
don't need to have
um fixed roles in practice that's often
what is done
um just for Simplicity but uh there are
some work with you can have like you
know uh both turns happening
um
but I mean also because the task is sort
of like uh symmetric this agent is going
for me by this attacks the other is
going from text to images so they share
some building blocks you know
Transformer reviews for instance but
they don't necessarily need to share the
same uh
um
so yeah what we're saying is we call
language
um this um mapping between meanings
um actually are images and messages that
starts as random given that the agents
don't have any pre-encoded linguistic
knowledge and sort of evolves gets
bootstrapped and gets somehow structured
um and become a random throughout the
game
um the game playing
some interesting things is again these
agents you have to see them as like
Pablo rasa they learn how to do the task
and as a side effect as a byproduct of
this learning how to referring to things
that do develop their own
for them for them meaningful language
um there is there is no direct
supervision on this direction on this
communication Channel again the only
supervision is feedback and this channel
is called um uh it's often cheap talk
from the literature which is a Costless
Channel meaning that the agents do not
have to pay any type of cost or penalty
when they generate a message so they
don't have any
um
um penalty to pay if they emit an
additional token or or something like
that everything is completely free
um
and messages are discrete rather than
continuous there is some research
investigating continuous Communication
in this setup but the reason why
um I mostly cover
um what what I studied what I think it's
relevant for us is discrete messages is
because if we are interested in things
like language Evolution
um questions related to language
Evolution then it makes sense to have a
discrete bottleneck there being that we
want to have a language which is
discrete that's similar to human
language and also because if we want to
have a more applied spin if we put
humans in this setup then there must be
some sort of discrete language like
interface for you want to to understand
to interpret what they're saying and
interact
um and some some might argue that you
know this this stack is is pretty simple
but I think uh the important bit is that
discrimination is is a very important
task to do and is the sort of building
block of more complex task if we are to
um interact with an environment
manipulate manipulating objects or do
things in the wild we always react to
the fact that we can refer and recognize
and discriminate object as the first
um step towards more complex abilities
um so
I'm now going to review a bit of the
relevant results that have been um uh
found in the literature and also some
other contribution exploding this this
setup
um this is a paper bilaterally from 2017
uh which is the first paper they use
natural images realistic images as you
can find them in computer vision data
data sets
um in this communication game in the
referential game
um so the agent would see
um two images and it was informed that
the target would be a pizza here
need to come up with a description and
then again the the receiver needs to
point to the to the pizza
and the Agents were trained as I said
with this reward and at the end of their
um of their training phase at test time
they would be presented with new unseen
uh images of the same categories and
without any type of training without or
adaptation they would need to use the
language that they evolved to still
refer to
um these unseen objects and turn out
that they can successfully with very
high accuracy almost perfect accuracy
um learn how to do this task with unseen
images and accuracy is computed just by
how many times the receiver can pinpoint
the right
object sort of like hinting that the
agents learning meaningful protocol that
allow them to correctly solve the task
and that this message is sort of
describing in the best way possible uh
the content of the of the images
quick question regarding terminology so
um basically what you call a language is
essentially a vocabulary just to look up
email that Associates uh images right or
inputs or prototype with uh with words
a language has much more
structure it's it's grammar
what exactly do a global language I call
language is non-random mapping and
it has been found that there is some
sort of structure that is similar to
natural language I mean another language
is much more complex but some properties
of natural language
as you can see later if you
um tweak the game a little bit do tend
to emerge
um in this in this vocabulary
require more complex languages
um but potentially this can be as like a
first step towards more interactive
things like if they develop their own
vocabulary then they might you know
combine in more complex Subs to like
need goals need direction to another
agent and then still like use this
bootstraps
if you don't put any constraint on the
message how do you prevent the agents
from just kind of repeating the the
input which this kind of discrete
uh so the message could be just you know
damage again right
I mean we here we are imposing a
discrete bottom line so it would be
something like
um
forcing this agent to sample from a um
from a fixed size vocabulary and
selecting like a fixed sequence of
cam tokens which is like sort of a way
of compressing so we impose some sort of
compression so the idea cannot really
um regenerate the image December it's
okay
I guess this there is no constraint on
length but there is a constraint on uh
you know how many characters you have uh
here this year yes yes
that this um this master generation is
often done through providing the agents
with a fixed size vocabulary
um which again is much smaller than the
input size
um and the agency can select a viable
number of tokens from this um quick size
I think you can see language as a sort
of like compression represent this with
representation of the reality
doing that well maybe I'm anticipating
but do you see compositionality so let's
say I have input that include Sports
wouldn't be a combination of tokens that
corresponds to each individual
so I'm not presenting results about
compositionality but there have been
many
um work trying to find it um so they I
think the taken about my messages
compositionality might emerge
but it's not necessary to solve the task
so it's sort of like happening as a
lucky
um you know convergence bar individual
response
but it's not a something that is really
needed for the agent to some task
I was like
quantifying and finding competitionality
I think it's a whole like some field
itself so it's not like a sheet of
property I'm just like you know Define
the question properly just on this so in
my mind I was like compositionality
emerges when it's necessary to solve the
task obviously but you're saying it
might also just happen to emerge even
when it's not necessary to solve even
when the environment wasn't designed
with compositionality in mind yes I mean
there is no correlation between accuracy
and competition yes it depends on the
yeah okay
doing some other guarantees for such
messages
I'm not sharing this in the question
about it you have to remember that his
Transformer base agents do not prevent
any type of knowledge of what a pizza is
they are untraded so they start from
scratch
it wouldn't have any you know embedding
learn embedding representation for the
pizza is they sort of just like learn
how to use
a representation while also development
um
okay so this sort of like show that
these agents can learn how to name
objects um which yeah maybe it's a more
precise example that using the
vocabulary of you know what I was
calling language
the follow-up work by busha court and
colleagues
um they replicated the the same setup
um let the agents play this uh naming
game this referential game
um and then they again passed this agent
on
um
um unseen objects and they they
successfully uh showed the same
performance that was reported in the
previous paper
um but interestingly why when a test
time instead of input coming from
natural images they provided the agents
with Blobs of random gaussian noise
which was completely
um undistinguishable at the naked human
eye so personally these agents were
still able to coordinate and recognize
which one was the target image among the
two with the same very very high
accuracy that was shown in in the other
test setup with real images or a
training time what was the difference
two different sampling of random version
noise same distribution yes
how can you distinguish two different
samples no but it's copied to the output
between these two they're the same but
they are the same position
and even I mean as you see here like
it's the same Pizza just like to say
North
if you swapped the
um in the previous slide if you swap it
with different images from the same
class like different image does it get
off the ground like does it work
s this is what they did here right so
but it's the same image of a pizza you
know
oh it can be like if you have different
uh yeah like uh speaker sees
some image of a pizza
mushrooms and then the list has
different images and the pizza now has
olives I'm showing this in a bit and it
has some nice
this
piece of language that you thought is
referring to a picture of what to
generate
also like a reconstruction game yeah
um I think that'd be interesting
um back then I think
people were going to be trying this
reconstruction game with real images
they were doing it with more like
disentangled representation of symbolic
people and have some results on setup
like that later
um I think mostly because it was really
hard to generate images uh there was
like you know discrete representation
learning happening around that time but
I guess in some Fields were actually
talking to each other
um but I'm not aware of uh any work that
tries to do it but
I'm also curious about what
language
like was it sequences
about yeah
um
but it was they actually had to come up
with a single symbol so it's like really
like picking your words
um so in this case it wasn't viable or
like length longer than one but
um in other setup yes you would see some
sort of like random achievements of what
would happen which you know my not seem
meaningful for us but they were being
improved for them
the
um American language is um is a genetic
language uh so it's not only looking
like human language and the
communication is happening
um through relying on low level
perceptual features of the input
something like hey the target is
um
the one that has the you know top left
pixel being larger than you know the top
right
um one
um which is not what we human do when we
say like when we convey the meaning as a
high level uh semantic information like
you know categories like dog a cat
um
I mean from their point of view it sort
of makes sense like if you as a human
were always
um throughout your life just ask to do
this simple discrimination game you
wouldn't need to use any type of more
complex uh clustering or representation
of your input and you might be as well
getting away with simply simple
um
communication strategies like you know
this low level perceptive features
communication
um and this sort of like tells us that
we might need to adapt a bit or setup
and our experimental configuration if we
want some more interesting properties to
manage
do some work that we did two years ago
where we have like a similar setup to
the one shown earlier then um you know
the center would see would see an input
images like a bike for instance the the
receiver would see again the usual image
plus what we call distractors
um but then this time so similar to what
you were saying we would be applying
um data documentation so data
documentation is this process that I'm
randomly perturbs the images
um modifying things like
randomly perturbing colors doing things
at random cropping
um
flipping of the of the images while
preserving preserving the semantic
content so if this is a Ligon here
um if you do run a random data
documentation you would end up with some
rotation or something like you know this
flipped one
um this means that the agent wouldn't
see exactly the same the same image um
they would they would see still they
would see they would still see this this
bike but it would be randomly slightly
different from for them while keeping
some imbalances
um and I think this is interesting
because it's very similar to how we
humans perceive the world so I I can
like talk with any of you and describe
and coordinate by saying things like can
you fetch my laptop and we wouldn't be
seeing the laptop from the same point of
view or under the same lighting
condition yet we are able to achieve
um perfect coordination and reference
referring to the to the object
um
after training the agents with this with
this light to a slight tweak to the to
the game they're able to coordinate on
unseen images like shown before but what
they did here instead is failing at this
test which is something we want them to
do this means that when the input was a
blobs random gaussian noise the receiver
would be performing at random chance it
wouldn't be able to recognize which one
was the correct Target uh random
gaussian noise
sort of telling us that at least their
communication strategies is not relying
on low-level perceptual features and we
hope it was we hoped it was relying on
something that is closer to what um
human language does and what we found
is um is shown here
um so basically here I'm just like
showing some symbol that they come up
with you can see them as labels or words
and I'm grouping the images
um random a random subset of the images
that were
um described by that given symbol and I
guess we can all agree that this
categorization is similar to uh some
semantic categorization of what robot
humans use even though it's not exactly
the same a category that the annotators
did in the data set because
um you know they would be saying like
the the type of bird specific bird that
this this one is but at least
we sort of understand that their
categorization is saying something like
a symbol one means to a bird
um on a branch of A3 or a symbol for
doesn't say bear or dog but it says
something like four-legged animal
um walking in the in the grass
um so we thought it was more like very
dark
um
by Niche object like here is for
instance like geometric shape on a flat
surface I mean you can come with all
sort of funny description of
categorization by at least
I think it's evident that there is some
coherence in this in this
um okay then
this is instead an interesting study
um from shabuni and colleagues and
materials and colleagues where they have
now the Reconstruction game
um with the input being disentangled
um representation of vector so you can
see this as indexes of um perceptal
features like you know color shape with
numbers being specific values within
this um perceptual axis
um and the sender would get this as
input and the receiver would need to
reconstruct and regenerate it
um and this is like a powerful power
load distribution I think it's about
showed yesterday and this is a property
that is found in human languages and
what they did is basically they sample
um input objects based on this parallel
distribution so they weren't uniformly
sampled when given as input to the to
the agent
um and these are interesting
um distribution because it's something
that has been found in human language uh
with a frequency and length
um of the of the words of the of the
messages being inversely correlated
the results is here so you can see the
red
um on the y-axis the message length on
the x-axis the frequency of the of the
messages
um the the the red line is for emerging
languages so protocols that are evolved
by the agents
um and at the bottom you can see the
green one has been some sort of optimal
coding for the um
input data and this other color line are
instead human languages like Spanish
English Russian or Arabic
um I think it's clear that the emerging
languages are not really showing the
same
um relation that natural languages have
they actually have the opposite one so
they have you know the fact they show
the fact that more frequent input in
here actually have the greater length
with a
as soon as we go towards the day of the
distribution land decreasing which is
the opposite that happens instead on
human lab
so is this always in the same situation
where there is no cost on the message
exactly the same person
this is where we add some constraints
so we I mean we sorry and they are
reading colleagues they said add some
constraints
um
some constraints on the um
on the um sender agent so the agent
would pay a penalty for generating an
extra symbol and the receiver would be
instead of force
um made more eager to to guess and and
solve the task and be being rewarded if
it correctly did after each symbol being
being generated so be impatient in any
sort of way
um so Top Line is some of their
implementation of these unconstrained
agents and the bottom line we see the
the red uh one being the the mean in
natural languages and the blue one now
being these constraint agents so I think
here it's interesting that not only now
there is some sort of
Ziploc distribution like arising but
um the property of this emerging
languages seem very very much similar to
the one on map of natural languages
is there any relation to the complexity
of the alphabet you're using so I think
in human languages and sorry if I'm not
using the right terminology so there is
this relation somehow between the the
complexity of the communication system
let's say number of different distinct
phonemes that they are in the length of
the world so overall the product is more
or less Do You observe something similar
here
it's really hard to talk about like
different levels of units in this
emerging languages
um there is there's been like some work
um that I'm just referring but not
showing where there is some sort of
um
more like phoning
um detection uh being applied to these
emerging languages but
um I think it's it's not really easy how
to disentangle these two representation
but being set up present in human
languages but not don't have a clear
mapping with this
and it's almost like
yeah it's also not super easy to like
complexity here it would be like the
number of unique messages in the
vocabulary that they develop
or you know might be like a bit of a
metric but it's an important question I
think it's sort of hard to like Define
it properly
yes on this there there was this work
that uh
language is a function of like
um
two parameters one is the number of
distractors for example it was something
like that or the ratio of the input to
the number of distractors and the other
one was the class of images like the
complexity of the class of images that
you will have to distinguish from
um so that was a couple and it it
perhaps like how you expect there but
it's
they did that nonetheless but it's not
really like alphabet two
yeah
um it was an iClear last year I can't
remember sorry but I'll try to find it
the second thing is on this
um
so
if you go to the previous before you add
the constraints and you have this very
strange behavior
um yeah exactly so I think the
explanation there was like oh it's
because it it the more meant the longer
the message the more powerful the loss
like signal that goes backwards I don't
know if they gave some like it's a it's
a strangeness of the architecture but it
just occurred to me also that
when you show these graphs although they
are they are the inputs to the language
sorted by frequency like
um natural language emerges not just
with constraints on communication but
also there are like a lot of
correlations between words and language
needs to
um I don't know accommodate that
um whereas in emergent Communication in
this game all the words that are
independent from each other you're
sampling independently so do you think
like this Behavior cost aside that the
cost is definitely super important to
add
um
if we sampled like with correlations
between words as well
um let's say If you think about
the co-occurrences of biograms and not
just you can see these agents as a now
the regressive model so there is not
very independency of where you're
standing right you're sort of like
even the model with other gasoline sure
it's um so there is some temporal
knowledge
I'm I'm referring or maybe I don't
understand how the game works but I
thought that the way this game works is
like for the purpose of this experiment
we have
um a thousand possible inputs and then
in this experiment we sample input
number zero
time
order of the time
and so on but there is no
like pairs of inputs that
correlate with each other in any way and
then dependence of the on the input side
yeah yeah I wonder if that like has
there been work trying to look at that
or would that be another like possible
explanation
um
I think it would be interesting to like
study where some few words that try to
modify the input distribution but sort
of like reflection of the real world for
currencies and see if that is also
protected in the language and that's
usually the case
um but I think here the point was more
like how the representation is
completely anti-efficient
it makes sense they don't have an
exclusive file so they just you know
generate as much as they can I like some
metabolic constraints that we don't
um
that these other words that sort of like
show how you know World boundaries can
be found uh even though these segments
do not seem to carry a clear cut meaning
like they do human language there's some
other work sort of showing you can study
cultural evolution of language where you
know like a pair of age and learn a
language and this gets transmitted to
new agents and sort of simulates the
evolution across generation
um yeah you can have Trader or I can
send me this but um
it sort of like covers most of the
analysis
um and now I guess I guess the identity
messages that it's often difficult to
use a structure protocol
um in a very implementation for some
definition of structure
um unless some explicit tweaks are added
to the to the game setup
and this might be okay if you only want
to test linguistic hypothesis you define
your hypothesis you add different
strains that you want to study and you
see how the effect your experiments but
if you care about
more about an applied scenario where you
might want to have agent and human
communicating
um this is bad news and this is because
we can easily map these two level of
abstraction or at least we can do it
very easily given our dissimilar um our
distance they are
and then that sort of like leads to our
um asking the question and making the
um
observation that if you want this
complex communication scenario
um deep emerging communication alone
might not get to get us that far
um and we should possibly look at how
large language models sort of develop
this very powerful
um linguistic prior
um and how they can be embedded in in
the communication game sort of dropping
this
um initial stronger assumption that the
agents shouldn't have any type of
pre-encoded knowledge
um so now in this um second part I'll
focus more on this
um deep emerging communication in the
language Model A large language model
era and um I'll present this uh setup
these are two papers that we need the
first one is uh the one I'm showing here
which is where an analysis paper
um and then the another one where agents
are actually learning to
um interact by playing the game
um which would be publishing next next
week at CPR
um whereas here there is no much
learning happening to interaction it's
sort of like everything is zero shot
they are just communicating after they
have been pre-trained with some sort of
language information and they're just
zero shot generalizing trying to
coordinate without any adaptation phase
um that's why here you don't need to
think about a tabular as agent anymore
but rather than an image condition
language model it gets an image generate
a caption knowing some sort of
[Music]
um
idea of language or how it should be
um generated if you get an input as an
image and here you should think about
the text condition image retriever that
get giving a caption sort of is able to
like point or map to the
um Target image and retweet it
um in this setup we use uh what we call
a contextual data set that's the image
called data set from Project colleagues
meaning that
um given an import input Target the um
the structures the other images are
sampled from
um consecutive framed videos and that's
why they look very similar and that's
why we call them as hard Destructor sort
of simulating how the real world we have
discriminate between similar objects or
have some close temporal
um discrimination to make what we use
language
I'm thinking for a second a step back
what did human did when they were to
play this game among themselves of
coming up with a description of this
contextual highly contextual data set
um they would say something ends are
stretching out of a piece of fur gold
nail polish on the right time is visible
and the tip of the time is cut off blah
blah blah and it's interesting to see
you know these images look very similar
and human come up with a very
um precise
um descriptive discriminative
description of the image relying on
these perceptual features it's actually
like gold nail polish on the right hand
is visible which is not the case in this
other image over here they would say the
first word and the first letter of the
text above the man at the desk are light
in white that's why you see they see
here
um if we play this game where you know
images are generated from humans and the
retriever is human
um and the random Baseline is 10 given
that there are 10 images to uh to choose
from performance is well above the
Baseline of 54 um percent accuracy in
retrieving the the correct image
um and that's instead very much lower
and closer to the Baseline if we use a
neural retriever sort of anything that
these models don't really understand
um this language or at least they don't
do like like we humans do
if we now turn about back to the to the
game where the agents where to generate
the captions uh what we see them doing
is saying something a person holding a
water bottle with a dog in it and you
need to remember that these are images
that were never seen by the agents
before
but at least on the idea of seeing these
two images and something looking like a
bottles it's it's there is some sort of
mapping between what this what they they
say what's your name
um over here they would say a picture of
a kitchen with a bunch of television on
it which again doesn't seem uh super
descriptive uh and surely doesn't seem
discriminative between these two
um but yeah that is what they came up to
I'm just asking a question that's kind
of unrelated do you think that it means
the picture or the kitchen and the same
before if you go to the previous one
there's dog ears in the background you
think that it is the picture or the
bottle
um I think here it's the weather model
okay
yes because it has fur like a dog no I
see that but
we don't know right right okay just
curiously meaning that the agent
attributes to these Wards are the same
to our understanding of the meaning of
this was in English or you can use the
English vocabulary to in code different
stuff I think that's actually the point
of this experiment of you know how if on
the surface it seems
um human language it is human language
and you know we might have very
anthropocentric we were like oh they use
language the same way we do it that's
this might not be the case
because I can use English words to
describe something completely different
they look like garbage which 10 games
like and this is what we call semantic
drift like this language yeah I think
that's really interesting
um so if we have this you know language
given to the neural models and we use a
human retrievers to play the game uh you
must are not able to use these uh
captions so performance drops very close
to a Baseline
surprisingly if we instead you know use
neural retrievers performance is
surprisingly high and we see you know
compared to the
um human
um captions a reverse pattern so
performance uh with neural caption is
well above chance
um when the neural retriever is given
hinting that agents are able to
understand this complex strategy like
you were saying you know maybe referring
you know to things differently compared
to uh humans do even though if on the
surface this is clear you're clearly
English language
for example regions in the image and can
you associate words with uh with
especially with visual elements to see
if what what is actually the meaning of
individual individual words in this
language I mean you might look at things
like in the attention patterns I guess
um but brilliant but I think
so in this neural neural is there any
training or it's just okay
captions are shorter
um and they also have a more complex
structures they use you'll see like we
hear human captions and dark Euro one
they use some objectives right series
conjunction whereas nearer ones use more
nouns
um and interestingly
um or at least y-axis is frequency
x-axis is part of speech here y-axis is
again frequency x-axis is um count that
counts so how many
um words we're using were used only once
only two three times and so on and we
see the new model
um cap can use many more times towards
only once so to use more like variables
more often
at least tell us that you know
there are different way of processing
um human versus machine language and
it's given by accuracy when the newer
retrieval was performed again
um but there are also different
production strategies between our humans
and machine sort of come up to this
description
um and again yeah this is across the
point mother was made even when it's
between language model process text the
resemble plain English their language
processing mechanism might might differ
from how weak that process language and
I think this might sound like a um like
a bug but I think it can be a feature if
we understand
um this gap between human and machine
protocols I think we might exploit it to
Define to the design better
um language model based human machine or
even
machine machine or heterogeneous
interactive setup
so very briefly trying to conclude I
think a bit of speculation where I think
we should go from here
um and I think sort of revising the fact
that you know emerging communication can
be an alternative to this
um passive language learning by
providing this interactive
um Paradigm I think it's important to
see them as sort of like collaborating
and sort of you know trying to see how
they can be uh there can be mutual
benefits between the two and
these large language models can provide
useful language mediated prior over word
and categories by the way they are
learning
um and the emerging communication setup
the framework and Analysis ideas can be
used to get insights or Define methods
on how we can model this functional
aspect
um of the language prior and sort of
like putting the language uh in context
and and being used yeah in a context
dependent setup
and this sort of like
should be seen as giving from diets of
tabular rasa agents to communities of
language models or you know each of them
might have been learning its own model
of the world similar to how we humans do
um and they need to adapt and evolve
their communication protocol by
interacting with other
um different language models and
achieving it as as I said more complex
and
um more useful
um skills than they can do alone
um and these can be even more useful if
we plug in this monetary genius setup
um humans
and
I think that's the juicy part how this
can benefit known like animal
communication and I think
the diets only set up might provide us
some sort of like methods or um insights
of how we can decode
um these non-human languages
um but what I what I really like and I
think it's sort of piggybacking on the
um idea of
if we are jamming uh with sperm whales
we might sort of have a way to generate
um interaction data I think this can be
a nice
um a nice framework to sort of uh
cheaply and in a non-invasive way
assuming that we have a good model of um
of the animal and assuming whether boo
way good way to model this interaction
we and we might have some some insight
from observing some
amount of data of this sort of jamming
interaction with the with animals we
might gather even more data and sort of
test in the lab
um in a cheap um useful way
um this interaction that we want to
study
so to conclude
um I first want to point to this um
Library so if you want to play with it
there is a library that is that we
developed at Fair uh that has some of
these abstraction algorithms and models
already implemented for you to try
um but to conclude I think deep learning
has proved as a valuable tool to provide
General learning machines
that are able to bootstrap in a random
communication protocol I think for some
definition of non-random or structured I
think we can see that
um and deep emerging communication can
be a part of powerful setup to study
Communication in this multi-aging
interactive scenario or also to validate
some theories of language acquisition
but especially if you're interested in
the more applied communicative setup
important attention should be paid on
the training setup given that important
tweaks should be applied if we want some
nice properties of natural language
emerging
um and exploiting the recent engineering
and research advances in language models
is I think where we should go if we want
to unlock
um The Best of Both words of having a
good language prior and putting this
language prior in use
that concludes my talk and it's sort of
like a summary of how I see work in
emerging communication going from you
know the reaction gathered towards
throughout the years where you know
people think that my friends think I
would be creating the next generation of
Terminator or the Press few years ago
that sort of like
um thought that you get this uh odd
combination of hyper parameters that led
to this wrong language that you know the
researchers had to control C to get the
good one was actually two weeks away
from the end of the world up to me that
you know what I think that I really do
is just like thinking about these
communication problems
um while coding and adding yet another
bug to my by torch code all the time
I think
pass the microphone around for questions
I apologize uh if you already said I
came in part way through the talk so if
you said this before forgive me
um when you
clip a bit did you use clip yes okay
okay cool that was do I have it
clip was our newer retriever or the
receiver agent
that we use okay and so when you were
doing this uh here yeah yeah
um so this was all using the same uh
latent representation you I put an image
in get a clip latent representation or I
put in ticks text and I get a clip
latent representation and then I compare
the distance okay
the two Transformer power the text
encoder and the Imaging code airplane
okay thank you sorry for repeating what
was already I didn't say it but I mean
thank you for the talk it was great
um back to when you observed that
inverse relationship between the
frequency and the length of the messages
my question was was there any type of
error correction observed like any
parity beat or something like that and
if not was this or is are there any
experiments using the same game but this
time through a noisy Channel
um
um I
I think most of the work that I'm aware
of
um doesn't take that assumption
mostly to sort of a simplify the setup
um and not add you know another variable
of
um you know sort of like altered
possibly the results I guess here you
know the question is what is happening
assuming you have a perfect setup where
you know there is no noise and
um there is no communication error
happening um
but I think would be interesting thank
you
[Music]
Michael made this point but uh I mean
really what we're talking about is a
vocabulary right because we're talking
about essentially ostension towards an
object is the task
um have you or has anybody looked at
emerging Communication in like an
agentic situation where you have two
agents that have a variety of tasks and
that need to communicate with one
another to accomplish those tasks
one of which might be identifying the
same object but maybe the other is like
coordinating activity because that would
seem to be way more analogous to what
we're talking about with dolphins or
whales right they have a whole variety I
mean they literally can't point to
things
um
um yes there have been some studies
where I think those are more
um within the like reinforcement
learning um embodied RL literature
um and even there sort of like the same
pipeline applies so the analysis work
sort of show that there is some
structure happening there is some
compositionality happening to a certain
extent
um and the tasks were again similar to
this one just in a more embodied setup
so like go into a specific object for
reaching a Target role or moving objects
um in the in the setup and again all the
structure that we're interested in
doesn't emerge naturally so I think
that's the technical message but if you
if you want some specific things like
um for instance like
verb-like words to emerge
um you might enforce this in the setup
but you know first communicating in the
first round something that would be like
what you have to do and then
communicating what the argument of the
action should do
um that is something that has been done
and has been found
right well thank you thank you very much
all right next up for Patricia and Jacob